okay what is the most significant
national security threat to United
States we have many security experts
here so I guess that makes sense as a
question from ank H the most significant
national security threat
pidgins genitals the sigh I would argue
it's education because we focus on stuff
that doesn't affect an American family
we spend a lot of money on Isis it's
what I did for a living they're going to
fight for Baghdad there's a small sliver
that might show up in New York City but
when we call ourselves exceptional we
don't give ourselves a capability to say
how does our educational system the
thing that will bring money to a kid's
life joy to a kid's life it'll keep them
out of prison how does it compare to the
Europeans and the Asians
how do we give an inner-city kid eh
inner-city kid the chance I had any
answer is we don't and so uh unexpected
answer well I'll see your education
surprised answer and raise you the
environment I think that's the biggest
and by the way you know who backs me up
on that the Pentagon I'm not saying they
say it's the biggest but the Pentagon is
very much on the page that the
environment and what we're doing to it
causes the kind of instability that is a
national security threat and they have
said so and Obama's quoted them that's a
long term I'd say long term China is the
biggest threat because it's the only
country with the global strategy they're
spending over a trillion dollars they're
trying to align countries towards
themselves ultimately undermines the
dollar and that's going to affect all of
us but in the near term it's the single
most powerful individual in the world
Vladimir Putin who is in decline and
very unhappy and wants to punish us and
the potential for costs in the next
cities well virtually in decline of the
country the countries in decline and he
is controlling so much power his ability
to do things that would truly cause so
do you think he'd do something crazy in
a rational uh I think that um well I
look I think we're punishing him and I
think his reactions he wants the
Americans to understand that's not
costless trust and so if you ask me
where you'd have an integrity
cyberattack against the big public
institution or a bank the sort of thing
that could really lead to
a surprise that we don't want this is
the cut this is a guy who saw the
missile defense system right to to Iran
yeah I mean so this is a guy who's
willing to take some risks and the work
doesn't worry about being an
international pariah any wedding talk
new crane okay but without blinking but
we invaded Iraq
you know we invaded Afghanistan to this
idea that we are in concert yeah I mean
we haven't figures my fingers at Putin
for invading Ukraine I don't think you
should do it either but first of all
it's not our problem
second of all the entire Palin family
working as a team couldn't find it on a
map and the the principal I said before
about let the you know Muslims take care
of the Muslim issue I think goes for
Europe to Europe is very rich remember
we're not going to do it every rich let
them take care of Crimea that's their
backyard not ours
we make everything our problem rights up
for taking care of the people in this
country right so one of the biggest
threats is the sense of hopelessness
that is going on in this country with
regards to community and police
relations in the african-american
community and the fact that you know
America's chocolates citizens are crying
out yet again in terms of the injustice
is and when people give up on a system
we have a problem and we're seeing that
hope you but you know why that is
because I think it's because campaign
politics they can't the Republicans
can't run on the economy because Mitt
Romney said that he would get
unemployment down to 6 percent by 2016
yeah and Obama got it down to 5.5 is
always hard to run on that I found that
what
they always have the trump card scared
the [ __ ] out of people yeah war is
always the Republicans trump card and it
works yeah I promise you the Republicans
are going to run on the economy with 11
percent unemployment when you take into
account people that are looking for jobs
or part-time jobs or have checked out
it's still 11 percent that's why
two-thirds of American people think
we're on the wrong track but Republicans
are thirds of people about I think we
still respond as Obama's weakest numbers
are on foreign policy he's bounced over
50% but on foreign policies in the
thirties except Hillary Clinton was
Secretary of State for four years under
Obama the Republican see that that is
going one of their easy ways is
Americans understand fun pop it off so
well well I guess if the if the earth
stops spinning it you don't blame that
on Hillary Clinton to I mean get over at
me a lot of these folks that are running
for president right now on the
Republican side are some of them are in
the Congress right now some of them were
former governors and what in the heaven
did they do well are they lifting to
make things better I think you have
power in your home state for example the
only quadrant razor can lower the
national level since Kasich is black but
so people a lot of the tech on a pair
you could attack Perry but Perry Perry
was a job machine down in Texas for a
long time are you I mean seriously one
that the children are living in poverty
right I'm just I'm talking about jobs
thirty percent of the net new jobs
created in America will create down the
fall y so you got well and criticizing
for other things but well the job
creation Republicans have a prerogative
that is because he poached those jobs
from other states which you can't really
do when you're president no does it when
you're president have to think about all
this year yeah but it's like there there
are huge issues out there which people
understand stagnant wages pretend for
ten years in terms of inflation just a
median income stagnant for ten years
Texas or in the Obama years by the way
and Bush years so listen let's get away
from one party or the other and let's
fix the problem right but a lot of
people rising but I do not agree that a
lot of these folks who are running for
president right now particularly on the
Republican side of the ledger had
opportunities and spaces to do those
things and they have not done it they
whisper sweet nothings in the ears and
so the main thing about them they want
to be the president the United States
that doesn't you can say the same thing
about Hillary Clinton foreign policy
right so the question is like where we
go
from here how are we going to get a
growing economy how the people in this
audience both electronically and
physically and so how are they gonna get
a good job where they're gonna be able
to afford to have their own home there's
20 million American families that pay
more than 50 percent of their income in
rent they don't have enough money to buy
a heart of it would be raise the minimum
wage
man but there but none of the
Republicans who are decrying these days
the wealth gap are them for raising the
right way I'd be like blow it's that
would start I mean you know there's a
lot of people who just live close to
like how animals were how can you live
if 720 bill I'm one of those families
build I know what it's like you know I
had a mother who died at the age of 42
years old any RISM burst in her brain
and she died on the system of warefare
and nobody grows nobody says that when I
grow up I'm gonna be poor I want to be
on the system who food stand that's the
life sweet deal everybody has hopes and
dreams and we need to focus more of that
attention you know yeah we got to watch
ISIL and everything that's going on in
the world we need to focus more of our
attention on helping Americans live out
their greatest greatness let's make some
investments here oh okay should the
should the army very apropos for this
week should the army allow transgender
people to serve openly yes well there's
no other way they can say yeah that's
pretty clear right yeah um it's on a
Don't Ask Don't Tell sort of thing right
that's right all right
but the army like makes you you know get
a crew-cut and and you know is it going
to work for for Caitlyn is you can wear
hair up
who says Caitlyn wants to go no I'm just
saying this is should they be a lot I
see yeah I say yeah we're gonna can you
do this we're we're not gonna good to
have a draft in any anybody who wants to
show up it's thrilling right that's
right it's true it's really unbelievable
and then and then and then you you know
then afterwards once they get out then
though you know be then they'll have to
deal with the VA which is gonna be a
barking problem right don't get you
started please no Louis black has comedy
changed with the advent of social media
that's what this person wants though
Peter are you know it's always the
[ __ ] same it's funny or not funny I
think I think maybe I think what he
means is like a lot of comics just doing
trying out new material and comedy clubs
have gotten in trouble because comedy
clubs we always thought was a place
where you experiment maybe you go over
the line because sometimes you have to
go over the line to find where the line
is yeah but a number of comics have
gotten in trouble because now everybody
tweets and they and they that's true
yeah and it and it's but if you may on
that yeah I don't give a [ __ ] anymore
you know live 11 we're inoculated we're
old yeah we they can't do anything to us
yeah I mean II know Holly but and a lot
of the people who come see me won't
remember I said it the last time anyway
okay do we have an affordable housing
crisis Rick Lazio's what should we do
about it yes sir we do yeah I mean it's
a huge problem out of people that are
what they call rent burden people paying
more than 30% of their income has
doubled over the last 50 years as a
percentage so in real terms as doubled I
mentioned before a 20 million American
family is paying 150 percent of their
income for housing both home ownership
and rental I mean that that means that
people and they're they're insecure
they've got to move multiple times
getting to your point about
education of kids get pulled out of the
school three and four times every time
you got to move out of your house you
were disrupting their social life
they're falling behind in class they
give up they feel I mean it's a this is
all they want one reason why there's a
housing crisis in a lot of big cities
it's because a lot of the space goes to
people not just in the top one percent
in the top point one percent who buy
these new york city london where i just
full of apartments that are empty almost
all year long they're second third
fourth fifth homes for the for the rich
people who don't need them don't use
them most of the time that's that's
where the space we spend we spend also
spend we spend two hundred billion
dollars federal government does on
housing most of it goes to people making
over a hundred thousand bucks I mean we
have if you make 250 thousand dollars or
anything over that there's just one rate
shouldn't it be a higher rate for if you
make a billion or ten billion should
someone making two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars the tax the same as
somebody making five billion dollars I
mean Nixon that socialist the tax rate
was 70% Eisenhower was closer to 90 you
know people making that kind of money
cannot spend that kind of money if they
tried in their lifetime we could use
that money we need to have a different
kind of tax rate but I don't think
that's something a Republican would ever
support friends I find out the trade-off
would be what would the money be used
for if you could if you could say the
money was gonna have to spent on
something that what would the money be I
don't see why I don't think Adolph no I
do care about the trade-off this is
really I guess you guys Lilly just
mentioned he'd arranged an education
infrastructure stronger if the money
went for deficit reductions so that a
militia uh yeah I think it'd be people
that would be open to that I think if
the money went for anything you wanted I
think that one of the most important
issues for billionaires that are coming
out with Republicans is to ensure the
tax rate stays low as possible for them
that is like if there's one thing they
want to spend it on that's critical so
you're not gonna move it
so it's barely worth of debate okay
thank you very much thank you very much
you